also ich hatte nicht mal 4000 abonnenten
das muss man sich mal vorstellen vor
drei monaten hatte ich nicht mal 4000
jetzt schon 20.000 ich habe jetzt 20.000
abonnenten und das ist einfach mega geil
danke dafür
hey leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video
ja und zwar geht es heute um den stars
stories oder so ich feiere das mega ich
habe auch instagram deswegen gefällt mir
das halt so weit instagram an sich auf
mega geil finde auf jeden fall schon
richtig viele youtuber gemacht ich weiß
auch gar nicht woher das kommt ob es
vielleicht aus dem amerikanischen raum
kommt wer weiß auf jeden fall wenn ihr
das wissen können ist ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben
ich mache mal schlimmer ist aber im
stadler und dann würde ich mal sagen wir
fangen direkt an also ich blättchen paar
bilder ein die ich irgendwann mal
gepostet habe und erzählt welche
geschichte dahinter steckt also ich
denke mal er versteht das und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß wenn es euch
gefällt gibt noch nach oben und ich
würde mal sagen wir fangen ganz unten an
und zwar ja ich habe instagram noch
nicht so lange das ist ein bild von 427
wochen und zwar ist das von meiner
formiert wir waren an dem tag ein jahr
zusammen jetzt sind wir schon eineinhalb
jahren zusammen und wir waren halt fotos
machen damit wir posten konnten können
dass wir einem jahr zusammen sind was
nur irgendwie so war das auf jeden fall
waren wir dann auf seinem weg und da
ging es rechts rein und da war sondern
halte abstellkammer und die kamera haben
wir dann auch sonne
wir haben angst dass die winterfeste
unstabil bar und wir saßen auf einer
bank seht ihr hier oben und zwar die
bank war auch mega wacklig also ich
glaube wenn wir da noch fünf minuten
länger drauf sitzen geblieben wenn wir
richtig auf die fresse geflogen aber
sind wir zum glück nicht so das nächste
bild ich zeig euch einfach mal die es
hier und zwar war das vor 15 wochen und
ohne scheiß 15 wochen ist ja noch nicht
ganz so lange her das sind jetzt
vielleicht 33 monate oder sagen wir drei
monate und einem drittel monat
also und da hab ich darunter geschrieben
4000 ich komme also ich hatte nicht mal
4000 abonnenten
das muss man sich mal vorstellen vor
drei monaten hatte ich nicht mal 4000
jetzt schon 20.000 ich habe jetzt 20.000
abonnenten und das ist einfach mega geil
danke dafür
und wenn ich dieses foto sehe dann ist
das irgendwie cool weil es kommt auf
sonne rein in so voll passend und ist
halt so dann ja ihr wisst ja ich war in
den sommerferien zwei wochen im urlaub
eine woche davon freuen und eine somit
familie in spanien und das foto hier da
war ich mit freunden in ungarn kennt ihr
bestimmt und zwar war das abends und ich
habe genau da zehn minuten bevor das
wort entstand ist habe ich 10.000
abonnenten auf youtube erreicht ist
gerade mal sieben wochen her das heißt
in sieben wochen noch mal 10.000 neue
und wir waren in einer disco oder so und
dann habe ich das gesehen habe ich mir
kommen machen wir mal foto ja und die
nächsten beine sind glaube ich nein ich
an einem tag entstand aber beziehen sich
bei also ziemlich auf das gleiche und
zwar war ich halt in ungarn hat schon
gesagt dann kam ich wieder und hatte
ungefähr ab schonzeit hier bis es dann
wieder los ging nach spanien genauer
gesagt nach ibiza fliege ich immer und
oder wir
und ja dann habe ich mir im hafen
gedacht ja kann muss er noch eine stunde
auf deinen auf deine fähre warten macht
sie doch einfach mal ein foto also das
ist am hafen von ibi zahlen standen und
das darunter das war genau am nächsten
tag da war ich gerade irgendwie
unterwegs und hat mir irgendwie gefällt
mir dass gerade wie das hier aussieht
und über kommt noch mal ein foto und
dann hab ich das auch hochgeladen und
war halt am strand ja und dann jetzt auf
ein zwei fotos zum schluss und zwar im
ihr wisst ja ich war beim video day zwei
tage und danach beim media kopf zimmer
klemmt
ich weiß ja auch wie das bistum bekannt
sein auf jeden fall sind wir dann vom
summer camp zurück am dom entlang habe
ich mir gedacht ich wollte schon immer
sein foto von und machen war der dom
grund ist und dann habe ich die
situation genutzt haben da hingen so und
dann seht ihr halt den dom im
hintergrund
ja und das war jetzt eigentlich auch
schon alle bilder ich kann jetzt noch
einmal 1 2 vom summer camp leinwänden
oder so auf jeden fall waren es jetzt
mit abstand die wichtigsten bzw die wo
am meisten story hinter steckt
seitenhalt leute und wenn jetzt bock auf
teil 2 habt dann gebt dem video einfach
nach oben dann weiß ich bescheid und
wäre das natürlich auch so schnell wie
möglich drehen auf jeden fall jacky
beschreibung instagram twitter habe
jetzt auch mal alles unten in der video
beschreibung und nochmal danke für
20.000 abonnenten hier auf der linken
seite dann geht's weiter mit boyfriend
tech3 das war mein letztes video und
hier auf der anderen seite lasst euch
überraschen ich wünsche euch viel spaß
mit beiden videos als ihr boot kappler
drauf zu klicken und ich habe echt mega
viel scheiße am ende